I actually recently just got into it  with my with my dad and so what you need  to do when you leave here just call him  and tell me you love him that's it  nothing to talk about huh doesn't matter  who's writing who's wrong dad I love you  and I respect you and I'll see you when  I get home because one of the biggest  mistakes I made because I work a lot so  it's easy to go I'll do it tomorrow I'll  do it tomorrow I'll do it tomorrow so  one day I'll get a call my sister's no  longer with us  so I'm already down you know from that  and I get another call hey man Kobe  Bryant just passed away and all I had to  do was pick up the phone and say hey I  miss you hey I love you hey what you  doing so after we get off this don't go  hang with these guys go in the back room  call your father say Dad I love you